de forma notável a horapronobs pode
ajudar a tratar várias condições de
saúde incluindo anemia hipertensão que é
pressão alta diabetes e problemas
respiratórios essa planta faz parte das
chamadas plantas alimentícias não
convencionais da sigla punk
PC que costumam ser tratadas como se
fosse invasoras ou até pragas por essa
razão muitas vezes são descartadas de
nossa dieta mas na verdade deveriam
receber mais consideração mais atenção
devido à sua riqueza em nutrientes como
vitaminas minerais e até proteínas muita
gente divulga que a orapronobis possui
cerca de 25 a 30% de proteínas em sua
folha e cerca de 85% dessas proteínas se
encontram em uma forma facilmente
digerível em partes Isso é verdade os
aminoácidos mais abundantes nessa
plantinha Milagrosa são a lisina e o
triptofano a lisina é incrível para
fortalecer a saúde do sistema imune do
intestino da pele e de cabelos já o
triptofano é perfeito para melhorar a
qualidade do Sono pois ajuda na formação
de melatonina aquele hormônio que faz
você dormir feito anjinho à noite o
triptofano age assim e de dia vai virar
serotonina que dá aquela levantada no
astral e ajuda a combater a depressão A
or pronobis realmente tem esse
aminoácidos em maior concentração Porém
Aqui vai a revelação pelo menos os
estudos nacionais a orapronobis pode não
ser essa fonte Espetacular de proteínas
que muitos divulgam por aí você já deve
ter escutado por aí que essa grande
quantidade de proteína presente na hora
pronobis já seria suficiente para
eliminar até mesmo a carne da
alimentação isso pode ser que não seja
verdade pode ser que não proceda porque
você teria que comer Grande quantidades
da Folha em 100 g das Folhas
aproximadamente 33 folhas contém cerca
de 3 G de proteína de acordo com estudos
mais recentes atuais brasileiros muito
pouco pessoal principalmente se você for
considerar que nem todo mundo consome 33
folhas de uma vez só bem Vamos aos
estudos eu vou deixar os links na
descrição um estudo interessante 2020
revelou que a or pron Seca tem muito
mais proteína do que a planta fresca só
para você ter uma noção numa dieta de
2000 calorias por dia 2000 k calorias
por dia a pessoa precisa consumir pelo
menos 75 g de proteínas para alcançar
essa quantidade seria necessário devorar
cerca de 3 Kg de folhas frescas ou quase
500 g de folhas secas Você consome tudo
isso outra pesquisa interessante
analisou o teor proteico da orapronobis
nas formas inatura e desidratada
mostrando que a versão são desidratada
at incríveis 23% de proteína enquanto a
inatura tem apenas
2,8 por ou seja o extrato proteico seco
dessa planta é muito mais interessante
para ser usado como fonte de proteína
vegetal por isso usar essa planta na
forma seca como farinha pode ser uma
ideia genial pessoal embora a quantidade
de proteína seja parecida com a de
outras hortaliças como a rúcula e o
agrião a proteína da H pronobis brilha
por sua maior complexidade e quantidade
adequada de aminoácidos os essenciais
nas proporções certas pessoal não quero
criar discórdia só acho que a informação
precisa ser passada de forma correta A H
pronobis é maravilhosa é barata e
acessível o seu consumo deve ser
incentivado mas vocês precisam saber que
tem umas informações aí desencontradas
divergentes por aí sobre as proteínas e
suas quantidades isso pode ser
prejudicial por exemplo para um idoso
que precisa de mais proteínas por conta
da sarcopenia né a perda de músculo da
idade está usando a planta como fonte
principal para obter essas proteínas o
que eu quero é que vocês estejam bem
informados e prontos para tomar decisões
sensatas até parecer outros estudos que
possam falar o contrário do que eu falei
até agora para cumprir o seu bom papel
como fonte Alternativa de proteínas or
pronomes é muito mais vantajosa quando
consumida seca comparada com outros
vegetais famosos como é o caso do grão
de bico que tem cerca de 9 g de proteína
por 100 g de alimento e o feijão que tem
5 g de proteína por 100 g de alimento as
folhas de or pronobis tem só 3 G de
proteína em 100 g mas adivinhe só esse
número dispara quando a planta é
analisada seca chegando a
impressionantes 15 g de proteína em 100
g
o desafio reside no fato de que a
farinha seca das Folhas da H pronobis
não é o método mais comum de consumo o
que pode sugerir uma falta de
conhecimento geral das pessoas sobre
Esse aspecto crucial essa situação pode
resultar no risco de deficiência de
proteínas para aqueles que consomem a
planta em seu estado natural sem ter a
ciência da quantidade exata de proteínas
que está realmente
consumindo isso se torna especialmente
relevante pois em algumas situações a
principal motivação para o uso da or
pronobis é justamente a suplementação
proteica pessoal a proteína mais
completa que existe é aquela de origem
animal porque tem todos os aminoácidos
essenciais que precisamos paraa nossa
saúde para veganos e vegetarianos a a
pronobis pode ser um excelente
complemento alimentar mas é essencial
manter o consumo de outras fontes de
proteínas como é o caso de Quino feijão
grão de bico ervilha linhaça algas e
cogumelos se deseja aumentar a sua
ingestão proteica com essa planta a
melhor opção como mostr os estudos é
consumi-la seca ou desidratada esse
processo pode ser feito facilmente em
casa utilizando para isso um forno em
Temperatura muito baixa ou mesmo expondo
as folhas ao sol para que sejam
desidratadas posteriormente basta
triturá-las em um processador Mas fique
AD ao contrário do que muitos dizem por
aí essa planta não pode ser a única
fonte proteína da sua dieta entre as
vitaminas encontradas na hora pronobis
estão a vitamina A que é importante pra
saúde dos olhos a saúde ocular e para
fortalecer o sistema de defesa o sistema
imune é riquíssima em vitamina C que
ajuda na produção de colágeno e na
absorção de Ferro em vitamina K que é
essencial paraa coagulação sanguínea
também Além disso planta é uma boa fonte
de vitaminas no complexo B incluindo a
tiamina que é B1 a riboflavina que é B2
a niacina que é B3 o ácido pantotênico
que é o B5 a piridoxina que é o B6 e o
ácido fólico que é o B9 de um modo geral
essas vitaminas são muito importantes
pro metabolismo energético para a saúde
do sistema nervoso e pra produção de
células vermelhas do sangue a presença
nessa planta de ácido fólico e do ferro
são incríveis para para combater a
anemia e todos esses nutrientes são
formidáveis para as mulheres que estão
grávidas ou mesmo planejando uma
gravidez porque isso vai proteger o feto
contra a ma formação O ferro é
fundamental paraa produção de
hemoglobina que transporta o oxigênio
para as células do corpo mas se você
está com excesso de ferro no organismo
ou mesmo Ferritina alta deve reduzir ou
evitar o consumo de
orapronobis outro benefício dessa planta
é que ela ajuda a equilibrar os níveis
de colesterol até mesmo a gordura do
fígado pode melhorar com o consumo dessa
Dádiva da natureza em relação aos
minerais a orapronobis é uma ótima fonte
cálcio Mais até do que a couve isso é
importante pra saúde óssea e pode
contribuir positivamente pro tratamento
de osteoporose do osso fraco Ela é Rica
em zinco fósforo manganês e magnésio
enquanto o zinco é importante pro
sistema imunológico e a cicatrização de
feridas o fósforo ajuda a manter os
ossos e dentes saudáveis já o magnésio é
necessário para inúmeros processos
metabólicos em todo o nosso corpo
inclusive para o relaxamento muscular e
controle da pressão arterial existe
outra propriedade interessante da a
pronobis conhecida pelo nome de
mucilagem a or pronobis é cheia dessa
mucilagem e de fibra
então ela dá aquela força na digestão e
melhora o trânsito intestinal combatendo
o intestino preso e até prevenindo
doenças do intestino grosso do Colon ela
ainda pode proteger as mucosas do nosso
trato gastrointestinal contra irritações
e as temidas inflamações diminuindo
assim os sintomas de doenças como
gastrite e colite a mucilagem presente
na hora pronobis pode ajudar a controlar
o açúcar do sangue porque Retarda da
absorção de carboidratos pelo trato
gastrointestinal isso pode ser muito bom
para quem tem diabetes ou mesmo
pré-diabetes ou resistência à insulina
você é fera um grande abraço e um beijo
no seu coração compartilhe os vídeos
faça bem a vida de alguém pode mudar
também no canal do Dr Alé do sear